congratulations new orleans saints they
have become the first team in the nfc to
clinch a playoff birth whether that's
the division title or
a wild card remains to be seen although
they have a three-game lead plus the
tiebreaker over the buccaneers they are
one game away from clinching the
division and they've won three in a row
with taysom hill at quarterback eight no
now dating back to last year with backup
quarterbacks in the game not a bad run
for sean payton and his backup
quarterbacks this one's different though
now look we saw teddy bridgewater end up
getting a nice contract with the
carolina panthers 22 million a year and
he's done well this year taysom hill
though a guy that sean payton has
compared to steve young a guy who is
just a blur when he runs the football
and you don't want to get in his way if
you happen to have an opportunity to get
in his way
he's developing as a passer chris and
yesterday in the win over the falcons
second win in 15 days by taysom hill and
the saints over the falcons
he he had
an impressive performance throwing the
ball and i talked to him after the game
i said what what's the reason for the
improvement in the passing performance
and he said
that
it's it's the timing and the timing with
the receivers has improved because of
not just the reps in practice but
working on it after practice doing all
of the
the the the reps
in your mind the the visualization he
told me that he spends every night
thinking about his footwork thinking
about his mechanics thinking about what
they're going to do against this defense
that defense runs through every play of
the game plan constantly visualizing how
it's going to go on sunday you put that
kind of starting quarterback commitment
into a body that has the skills to get
it done especially now from a passing
standpoint we're seeing it
and and i said to him are you have you
proven
that you are a week in week out starting
quarterback in the nfl and he said yeah
and he's talked to sean payton about it
and i think that they understand
he's either going to be the guy after
brees or he's going to be the guy
somewhere else yeah that's right but but
but he's he's done enough and i know
there's still there's just this strange
anti-taysom hill cult out there that
just wants him to fail to prove that
they were right when they had their
knee-jerk reaction that he was a fluke
and he was like a tim tebow isn't that
stupid that people are that way yeah
like not like with josh allen i hear you
that's why you hear me get mad all the
time they're still living off their
college review on them okay let's move
past it now he's proved that wrong i
know you were wrong for the first time
in your life so what it's football
you're gonna be wrong a lot i know it
people won't get over it i don't know
what it is either mike
we have to speak our hot take into
existence so anything that happens that
advances our narrative becomes the
headline and anything that cuts against
it gets ignored i feel like too many
people are doing that with tayson hill
and fine he'll just keep playing and
he'll just keep winning and i don't know
whether we'll see him this weekend i
think we will see him against the eagles
i think the earliest we're going to see
brees is next weekend against the chiefs
which uh circle that one that should be
a pretty impactful game wow but taysom
hill getting it done
and uh the other thing he told me too
and and i love this because every year
sean payton's got another gimmick
another prop he's like carrot top with
the things that he does to to get
messages across to his team but he's big
on the bill parcells don't eat the
cheese yeah message so he put baskets of
cheese in every player's locker
uh and uh i said well what kind of
cheese he'll say every kind of cheese
like big baskets of cheese to send a
message of don't eat the cheese and uh
you know it's uh you do what you you do
to get to get these guys to understand
they do have to knock these off one at a
time because they've had their hearts
ripped out every post season for the
last three years and they wanted to
change this year obviously yeah no i
mean it's first off i i guess you know
the taste some hill you know just one
little thing there
he he's showing us
you know there's plenty there from him
as a drop back quarterback standpoint to
go oh there's a lot of good to build on
and let's not forget i mean his running
is a real thing you know you can't take
that away from a statistical output so
yeah it might not look the same as for
drew brees but the running success of
the football team is also a lot
predicated on taysom hill and what he
brings to the table he makes things
easier for alvin kamara and latavius
murray because teams are worried about
ooh taysom hill might keep the ball off
the edge and then of course him just
actually running for 83 yards is special
that way too but like when you take over
as the starting quarterback i don't know
if people always realize this like i bet
you taysom hill hasn't thrown a pass to
michael thomas all year long until he
got named the starter when you're in
training camp drew brees gets the throw
to michael thomas and the starting
receivers all the time you never get to
do that so when you're thrusted in there
all of a sudden in week 9 and 10 you're
going wait i've been thrown to scout
team guys and practice squad players and
all that stuff this is a little
different speed and aggression out of
cuts and this player's a different
player so there's some getting used to
there and the last thing mike
we probably need to talk about like sean
payton as coach of the year more i feel
like he's gotten to that status where
he's so good every year now we just kind
of go ah
we know he's good we don't need to give
him the word and that's kind of bs you
know i think that happens with him in
belichick a lot here over the last four
or five years
hey we drafted coach of the year not
that long ago and i made him one of my
candidates and people were like what are
you talking about well nine straight
wins that's what i'm talking about you
know it's it's that perfect it takes a
while to figure out what we've got right
and then once we figure out what we've
got we're going to kill you every week
and yeah if drew brees gets hurt we'll
be fine with the backup and just off we
go and uh you know it's it's it's fun to
watch it happen
and that defense has gotten so good
one of the reasons and yeah i don't i
don't want to go back and
and and delve too deeply into the bounty
scandal although i think it was complete
and total bs it was an example of a
cultural reality in the nfl that's the
second time it's come up today because
greg williams was the centerpiece of it
but
that lost year of 2012 really through
their defense especially into a tailspin
and it took him a while to recover 13 14
15 it took them a while to get back to
where they needed to be and they finally
got the defense back and there's a
reason why they've been great 17 18 19
20 remember brees told us
back in miami before the super bowl he
actually thought about retiring after
the 2017 season because he'd suffered
through
all those mediocre years he was just
that's it i i this may be it for me and
that was the year that they've they've
found this unprecedented run of success
four straight playoff appearances for
the first time in franchise history
chris yeah it's uh it's impressive i
mean just for everything the way the
team is built you know the different
styles in which they can win the
coaching adjustments on the fly
throughout the year everything the
defense has been
the most dominant defense in football
the last four or five weeks i i don't
have any problems saying that it's very
spec dennis allen's killing it on that
side of the ball their defensive line
dominates it's one of the best offensive
lines in football as well to go along
with that you know sean payton you know
that's that's what's cool about him yeah
he's this passing wizard genius and all
that but he's got this bill parcells
and he's told you this before run the
football in the back of his ear and like
physicality and you know 1987 86 new
york giants type mentality too which i
think is really cool combination of how
he coaches
it it's uh going to be fun to watch what
the saints do down the stretch and uh
they lock up the one seed and and and i
just wonder
whether and to what extent if they have
home field advantage for the post season
what kind of a deal can they strike
locally right to get some fans in the
stadium uh that that would be compelling
because any edge they get is going to
help them win those games and advance to
the super bowl in tampa all right
deforest buckner was back for the colts
this week he tested positive for covet
19. he told me he had no symptoms i
spoke to him after the game he had two
sacks at deshaun watson no symptoms felt
fine watched the game it was killing him
to not be out there because he knew he
could have made a difference against the
tennessee titans definitely made a
difference yesterday and the two sacks
of deshawn wants and we talked about how
difficult it is to track down to sean
watson and i was reminded of aaron
donald talking about
sacking kyler murray and the fact that
he's been chasing around russell wilson
his whole career makes it easier to get
kyler murray and i asked buckner your
time with the 49ers how much of that
chasing wilson chasing calamari last
year helped he said it's a huge
advantage it teaches you how to how to
go after a guy who's that elusive never
try to arm tackle a guy who's that
elusive and you almost have to strike
you know when you get your chance you
strike you don't let him get moving you
got to get on him while you can he did
it twice yesterday the texans gave the
colts a much better game than many
thought they would the texans have been
impressive and they had a chance to win
it late but for a botched exchange yeah
after a snap at you know maybe they
would have won that game and we'd be
leading and talking about a very
different set of circumstances right now
in the afc but uh
you know buckner on the field makes that
defense dramatically better yes and now
they're back in a tie for first place in
the afc south and four games to go and
if they win that division they're going
to be a team to be reckoned with in the
playoffs yeah
no doubt well i mean he he kind of gets
like lost in the shuffle a little bit
for whatever reason because he just
doesn't it's not always eye-popping
stats but it's like hey would the rams
be as good if aaron donald was on the
defense oh no they wouldn't well i know
deforest buckner's not aaron donald but
he's in that upper class of like really
special defensive lineman and football
and i do have a hard time thinking the
tennessee titans run the ball on the
colts like that if the force buckner
buckner's not there no you know there he
he's a force to be reckoned with and it
just allows them to not have to blitz or
pressure do none of that as much as you
know you'd want to just because you
don't want to stress your defensive
backs and everything watson was
phenomenal in the football game
yesterday game was funny i mean it was a
first half back and forth shootout and
you went wow this is fun i mean this
looks like it's going to be like a 41-38
final and then all of a sudden the
second half nobody could sustain a drive
or keep anything going until that last
drive with watson and you're just
thinking deshawn watson at the five yard
line
is almost like
it's like aaron rodgers or patrick
mahomes when they get down there you're
just like it's they're going to score a
touchdown it's just what play is it
going to happen
and you know to have the bad snap
like that kind of just fitting for their
whole year a lot of good but uh just
that one thing or that one bad moment
that kind of ruins everything
it's raiders texans
jaguars for the indianapolis colts the
rest of the way and currently tied for
first place in the asu south with the
tennessee titans
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports